okay
I mean y'all I'm ready timing people the
most anticipated event of the year is
finally dropped it's a it's officially
fall I love fall September 22nd is the
official beginning of The Fall season
and I just love fall so much one of my
favorite things about fall comes in a
cup so today I'm going to show you how
to make my very own mulled wine recipe
delicious this recipe was actually in my
special edition When Christmas Comes
Around autographed box set last year I
think I hope I got that right
um but it came with it we want to do
something kind of cute this recipe
literally couldn't be simpler because
I'm not good at chemistry
what's your first memory of drinking
mulled wine when you go to Germany and
they have those Christmas markets
and they're magical and you buy these
little cute things all over the market
and the food is amazing and you walk
around and it's freezing but it's
awesome because you have mulled wine
German Christmas markets they know where
it's at we should start that here why
don't we do that we're dumb okay so into
a medium sauce pan you just add one
bottle of red wine that's right Bottoms
Up
okay so now we're gonna add six whole
cloves so beautiful little cloves here
we go one two
three
Duolingo would be so proud five whole
cinnamon sticks three
four or five and then we're gonna add a
three star anise I just love this name
and they look beautiful oh wait that's
not a full one let's get a full one
that's not either
I'm gonna get a full one
look at that boom and boom
oh oh that smells so good it smells like
Christmas don't forget about the oranges
take a whole orange slice it into rounds
and put it in there as well you can set
some aside for garnish
okay so you have a fourth a cup of honey
I love honey not because I'm a vocalist
either I know a lot of people are like
oh I like some tuna no I just like it
because it's good and we would not be
here without bees thank you for this
honeybees boom boom boom I have to have
like sounds because I'm in the kitchen
any extra special Bit of Love is a half
a cup of Brandy
yeah it smells like a good time
then you just bring it to a simmer um
don't let it boil don't ruin it okay
bring it to a simmer and let it simmer
on medium to low heat for like 10
minutes your house is gonna smell
magical while we're letting this simmer
it's time for some fall favorites
pumpkin pie with whipped cream on top
don't even come at me without the
whipped cream on top it's just it's the
chemistry of the nice freshly whipped
cream like on the pumpkin pie with a
nice thick crust like don't come at me
with some crazy cheap stuff I want this
is when you spend the money this is when
you buy a really good piece of pie my
mouth is watering my God I love pumpkin
pie and I generally only eat it then so
this is looking good oh which tumbler oh
I like this one because that's all the
colors
cute little wooden laid old con now
even the sound
the woods scraping along the bottom of
the pot and then just being poured in
oh
she's getting
she's getting in it
gosh it smells so good
I'm gonna put this I'm just gonna drop
it in there I could have done it cute on
the side but I want it in there
foreign
yeah okay
I mean y'all
I love mulled wine it tastes so good
it's so warm can you imagine being in
the snow and you come in you're like
well why it's so hot coming straight out
of it though it's like steaming it's not
weird drinking this in like 80 degree
weather in La no I don't like cold
drinks often it could be 120 degrees and
I'm still having a hot latte Yep this is
good you're welcome Happy fall everybody
we have so much holiday magic coming up
on the Kelly Clarkson show we love it
this is our favorite time of the year so
please let me know in the comment
section like your family's delicious
like fall faves and stuff because maybe
you'll turn me on to something that I
might like and I'm gonna take this with
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]